bullet hit podcast man we got the homie
j stone in here
welcome what's up what's up what's up
man what's up kev
hey yo we chillin man listen your new
album uh the definition of pain
is uh is is well look what's today
this is gonna release when this the
album is out all right so the album is
out
um a great body of work man you know i
got to appreciate you sending it over
early so i could tap in with it man
definitely a
very personal project i feel like um
obviously with the title man kind of
give us a little
window into your thought process behind
naming the album
what you named it i mean you know um
you know nick really gave it these
titles you know what i'm saying
with the definition of loyalty yeah you
know what i'm saying you know i let them
hear a lot of songs and [ __ ] before i
even dropped the definition of loyalty
and bro it's like man just based on the
stories and
you know what i'm saying you're giving
the g codes on [ __ ] and you know what
i'm saying like man your album should be
called the definition of loyalty you
know what i'm saying because what i'm
getting from these records is like
loyalty
right right [ __ ] like that you feel me
and he like man your next album should
be
the definition of of something else i'm
saying
pain sacrifice success you know what i'm
saying i just got to start thinking
about all that [ __ ] and i'm like that's
a [ __ ] life right there though if you
think about it
yeah you uh you know early on in the
project you're talking you know for
people who don't know kind of give us
the background you lost your mom when
you were three years old
she was young i think you said she was
25. she was only 25
you know what i'm saying and i was only
three so your auntie helped raise you
yeah my auntie you know i'm saying which
was her sister what happened
with your mom why did she pass so early
if you don't mind sharing [ __ ] the
police man you know what i'm saying that
was 1989 you feel what i'm saying
uh the crack epidemic was crazy you know
what i'm saying the uh
the police force in the streets was
crazy you know what i'm saying it was
just a war on drugs just for me so
anybody out
anybody out there that was selling or
using
there was a target period you know i'm
saying you go to jail get killed
in a process so your mom
was killed during an interaction with
the cops yeah man
[ __ ] man she got pulled over on some
[ __ ] man
you know what i'm saying [ __ ] i don't
think she wants to go to jail you feel
me she probably talked to him crazy
probably resisted the rest or some [ __ ]
who knows
yeah it's crazy too because like we
think about police brutality and how
over the last like
seven eight years it's been so magnified
in social media
yeah but it's it's crazy because when
you go back and you watch
like you know obviously not being from
la
i'm from phoenix but like watching like
you know the menace to societies the
boys in the hood and like the way
the cops were portrayed in those movies
it's like almost like it was worse back
then
and there was no cameras yeah it was
worse back then like they fabricated
how the police really act in the movies
and like
like like they dumbed it down like done
they dumb that [ __ ] down but they
over exaggerated how [ __ ] programmed
in the streets you get what i'm saying
the streets was turned up like don't get
me wrong but you know like the movies
they made it a little bit dramatic you
feel what i'm saying
yeah um how like
you know at three years old i don't
remember much from three years old
obviously
um like what was that like though kind
of like you know like how did your
family kind of
once you were getting older like you
know what i'm saying like how do they
kind of
let you know what happened because
that's kind of a tough thing to tell a
kid on i'm like yeah this is what
happened to your mom
hey you know look so that's why i kept
getting like different stories you know
i'm saying i had to put this [ __ ]
together
because i would ask you know what i'm
saying my auntie i actually know what
i'm saying a cousin
a uncle or somebody and i get all
different stories
right because you're a kid they won't
they don't want to tell you know wild
[ __ ]
they're probably either sparing my
feelings or they didn't even know
um you get what i'm saying so it was
just i was getting different stories so
like the three different stories i got i
put them all together
and you know what i'm saying came down
to the bottom of that [ __ ] and i asked
my granddaddy like hey man
this like did this happen he like that's
exactly what happened you from what i'm
saying [ __ ]
cuz they telling me she this she died
right
you know what i'm saying so once i got
the real my granddaddy was like man
that's exactly what happened like you
know what i'm saying um
for people who i've obviously kind of
break down like the section of la you're
from
like you know i think anybody who who's
fans of nip and
are already tapped in with your movement
kind of already understand where you're
from but like for people who are
watching this
who don't know kind of like give us a
background on what part of la you're
from
i'm from l.a i'm from south central you
know i'm saying the crenshaw district
you know i'm saying i grew up on 8th ave
you know i'm saying i went to hyde park
elementary went to crenshaw high
washington high
you know what i'm saying it's crazy
because because crenshaw high has become
um
like a cultural like landmark you know
and
i know nip had a lot to do with that
like even back to when he had uh
those pony shoes and they were the the
blue and the yellow and yeah
yeah hell yeah yeah yeah man crenshaw
crenshaw itself man you know what i'm
saying got a history within
itself you from saying and and and
and and nip and nip you know what i'm
saying he just recreated
the history of it you know what i'm
saying we had history then with the
daryl strawberry
and of course you know what i'm saying
and all that and
yeah man it brought that [ __ ] back to
life bro in a worldwide
international scale like you know what
i'm saying
you say nip uh you you got out of jail
and nip put you on a beat
as soon as you got out soon i came
on so give us a little background on
your relationship with nip how y'all
how you guys originally linked up and
obviously for you to get out of jail and
then i'm
automatically you know be tapped in with
the with the with the homie like like
give us
give us a little background on that yeah
hell yeah i mean [ __ ] when i got out of
jail and [ __ ] man bro came
and picked me up you know what i'm
saying from jail he like bro man we
could
we could do whatever will you was this
well chip
what year wasn't it like he didn't i've
been in jail
[Music]
2013 when i finally got my [ __ ] together
okay i came home
january 2013 with a plan
with a plan not to go back and just get
it right
stay in the studio you feel me so when
bro ask me what i want to do
he said that i want to go [ __ ] with some
hoes [ __ ]
we go get on the helicopter we go do
whatever you think i'm saying i'm like
bro take me straight to the studio
wow you know what i'm saying and we went
straight to the studio that's crazy he's
cracking he threw me on the beat
we got cracking and they're gonna get
right yo it's crazy because like what
you just said is uh like you've been
like you you've been to jail multiple
times and then in 2013 you finally
kind of was like okay yeah i feel like a
lot of a lot of like i have cousins who
have been in and out of jail nonstop
their whole life right and it's like a
lot of it
it's hard to get someone to really
understand why
they they're in that position over and
over again a lot of it has to do with
the people you surround yourself with
yeah the circumstances you choose to be
around you know what i'm saying yeah
cause after a while they think your ass
dumb they'd be like man this [ __ ]
stupid this [ __ ] like jail or something
why this [ __ ] keep going back yeah like
what what
i don't understand i would ask you like
what is some advice you give somebody
who has that problem because there are
people who are good people who
just keep getting wrapped up in you know
that the cycle of just
going in and out of jail every couple of
years you know what i'm saying to be
honest
to be honest with [ __ ] man like on
some real [ __ ]
the system is set up for a [ __ ] to stay
in there to go back you feel what i'm
saying
like they be pulling 15 year olds over
you know what i'm saying fresh
out of school because they want you on
probation early they want to get your
own paperwork get your own
probationaries then they can just
[ __ ] you over every time for your rights
so then when you do go to jail
uh and you get out and you're still on
probation or you're on parole
any little thing that you do violations
yeah i could be chilling with my family
member and this [ __ ] on
probation of parole you but you can't be
affiliated with those kind of people
bro yes so that [ __ ] right there have
your ass back fast
yeah i feel like that's the biggest
loophole is like especially if you're
from where you're from it's like yo so
you're telling me i can't be around my
my cousins or yeah you know anybody
that's you know what i'm saying
affiliate but that's damn near whole l.a
oh you can't live in the gang
neighborhood what do you want me to do
the whole l.a right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right right right right right grand mom
standing somebody hood auntie standing
somebody hood mom standing in somebody
hood you feel what i'm saying
help me understand on the album you say
um baron davis and ronnie richard blood
cousin
yeah real talk so your blood cousins
roddy and baron
real talk i said i didn't know i didn't
even know that roddy and baron were
related like that
they probably don't even know they
probably didn't even know you said what
i'm saying
like it it it it just it just it just
it took a [ __ ] a little bit later to
to know that part you feel what i'm
saying especially roddy cause my bro hit
me was like
he was like you know roddy that's our
cousin right
that's a little you know what i'm saying
there's a little government now he like
you know that's
i'm like yeah [ __ ] roddy
is my my my g pops my jeep no
my uncle is his g-pops oh [ __ ] i go
so you guys are like for real related
that's crazy you guys have my dad that's
my dad brother my dad brother
my dad brother is my uncle mm-hmm that's
that's that naked granddad
were you um like like is that something
you found out recently or was that
man yeah i just found that out recently
bro
like you've probably been around them
and [ __ ] not even knew it his g-pops is
my favorite uncle
oh wow okay like that's that's what's
crazy about it
damn so you were like you guys i because
i'm assuming you were around like with
the racks in the middle
uh well you were watching the video yeah
that's what i'm saying
obviously you know hit always tells us
that story about
how how legendary that session was you
know um
but yeah but you didn't even know that
was your cousin at the time that [ __ ]
crazy
that part i didn't know i found that out
later on in the game though that's crazy
that's crazy how this [ __ ] be bro yeah
super crazy what about
obviously baron davis legendary la
figure one of the most slept on point
guards in nba history
yeah man he's super tapped in as well
yeah
you know shout out to b diddy uh you you
guys have a strong relationship or
sure hell yeah yeah i pull up on him
faithfully
you know what i'm saying we have talks
you know what i'm saying we catch up
we reminisce how was it nice that when
he was on the clippers was that nice to
have like
man that's why that's why i'm a hell of
a clipper fan right now you know what
i'm saying not really not from l.a but
like
you know what i'm saying my cousin brian
played for the club he was balling out
when he was on the clippers
for real yeah i had a [ __ ] play for the
clippers the warriors
hornets hornets knicks for a little bit
next for a little bit
yeah i'm saying you know the warriors
was the wave though when he when they
had that uh
that season uh where they were they
upset the one seed i think it was they
beat the mavericks in round one
yeah it was like matt barnes barry davis
michael peterson that [ __ ] was legendary
yeah that's crazy
so um this album man super personal
album i feel like um
you know you got some records on here
that are crazy you got
two nipsy features on this project that
are
like very special records i feel like
the lebron james record with dom kennedy
is a
is a banger yeah and i feel like the
other one is
one of the better knit verses i've heard
in a long time man like
yeah he got off on that [ __ ] yeah now
do you now now go ahead go ahead no no
go ahead i was gonna say like
what is the process of like how many
unreleased nip
records do you have obviously your home
team
so i'm assuming that you you uh you you
have some you know i know
you know dave east uh who's on your
project a couple times as well
right he's you know he's got some [ __ ]
with him that no one's heard
but like see see now that last you know
what i'm saying that second song you
heard you feel me that was like an
energy
that we was in the studio and had did
like
cuz went crazy and then i went crazy
right
but the verse that i use is not is not
even diverse you feel what i'm saying
bro was like he said [ __ ] everything
you said on there was the money he said
just change the first four bars he said
he changed the first four
bars he said the rest of that [ __ ] is
money
so instead of changing the four bars i
just changed the whole verse and just
went crazy
yeah you smell you spat yo cause nip
kicked that thing off man
on fire yeah but we held on to her for a
cool minute right right
right and we ain't you know i'm saying
we ain't do [ __ ] to it so
after a while just started getting
outdated i revamped the beat
and i'm like man this [ __ ] perfect for
the album yeah because i know that
nipsey was like
very uh like he had intent when he
recorded it wasn't like nipsey wasn't
the kind of guy who would like
you know do 150 songs and like you know
you know there's those artists that like
quantity over quality sometimes right
but i feel like nip everything he did
was like very um
specific it had purpose it was like you
know like
so so in your in your estimation like
how much
nipsey versus records
that are you know on hard drive
somewhere that we haven't heard yet
hey man a lot it's so much music this
[ __ ] didn't did bro like you
you you wouldn't even imagine bro it's
[ __ ] that i haven't even heard
when i thought i heard everything from
saying like is there a
have you heard any i like like plans
obviously pop smoke passed and we got a
his a crazy album from him after he died
after he died and i think
that you know a lot of nipsey fans are
like i wonder if we're gonna get one
more nipsy project
and i know it's not gonna be as cohesive
because you know he's not here to
if if it were to happen he's not here
it's gonna take a lot of production it's
gonna take a lot of you know
is that something that's been discussed
it's going to definitely
be another nip album you know i'm saying
but you know you got to take time with
that though money in
so you know we ain't gonna put out
nothing mickey or
do it just exactly for what i'm saying
you guys felt like
like you know what i'm saying wrestling
piece of pop
i feel like if they would have held on
to his music a little bit
more you know what i'm saying and put it
out the right way it would have been
received different
but the music was still good and we
needed it at that time so you know yeah
they definitely um
after after park died i feel like
they didn't take their time with putting
together those projects as much as they
probably could have
yeah and nip had his brand and his image
so
so so strong and tight like
you can't you know what i'm saying you
can't do the puck on them with the
machiavelli one
machiavelli 15. remember all those cds
i remember just hearing about all those
yeah and then when napster came out i
was downloading all the [ __ ]
tupac bootlegs off the [ __ ] internet
man right yo that's crazy
yeah cause i i do think there is
something to be said about
like with pock like there was like some
of those
post-death albums that were solid but
some of them just felt like they just
kind of
kind of threw [ __ ] together and it was
like can't do [ __ ] together when they
could have waited and then there was the
one album that had like features with
people he probably never would like
everybody even did a song with bro like
why is
doing a song with trick daddy and and
all like and g-united [ __ ] like bro like
he didn't even know these cats you know
what i'm saying like and i feel like
with with nip it's got to be very
you got to take your time if that
project happens
everything's got to be super you know i
mean the same way he took his time with
victory lap
yeah and it was a perfect album for sure
in the same way you know what i'm saying
so
that'd be crazy though if we hear that
man um yeah that'd be crazy i don't know
i really can't say but i just
well you did say earlier
but listen man shout out to nip i hope i
hope we hear
uh because you know some of these verses
that have been coming out deep reverence
with sean was crazy
uh the the you know the stuff on your
albums like
there's been some the the uh obviously
the khalid record was special yeah i'm
glad that they that they
got to release that video yeah yeah nip
got a chance to pull up on khaled
at his crib you know what i'm saying
they vibed out and knocked that [ __ ] out
there
uh i was talking to dave east um and he
said that you guys might be
doing a collab project yep you and dave
yeah we definitely like halfway through
an ep
you know what i'm saying i mean he's on
i mean look you guys got some great
records together
right now yeah right now yeah yeah you
heard like two of them already
for show for sure yeah so uh with
because i know
easton nippet talked about working
together so that's got to be a very
important like uh you know
hey dave's one of the realest dudes in
hypno just a great guy
very genuine dude he's solid bro so you
guys are halfway through it 100 yeah
halfway through and we ready to go man
we going we we ready to just finish this
[ __ ]
get it going you know what i'm saying
him and nip obviously was working on one
you know what i'm saying and uh yeah man
we just gonna keep this [ __ ] going
help me understand the t uh how did you
get t pain on this album man cause i
i was just listening when i looking at
the tracklist i heard t-pain
i was like oh [ __ ] yeah man t-pain on
the album shout out to t.i though man
for real i put up on him and
we got in the studio and uh the producer
that produced for uh
for tip you know what i'm saying has
some music for me yeah
yeah he had the t-pain hook yeah
yeah he been holding on that for me he
like brought been having this record for
you man i've been sitting on this record
for you
he had hit me in june and told me about
it so did you have to hit pain to clear
it obviously right like of course yeah
and he gave you the blessing yeah we got
the blessings man shout out to tip man
so t.i helped kind of run that come on
man hey that's crazy
yeah cause it sounded like some vintage
like you know some like all the above
era t-pain i was like this [ __ ] i
haven't heard pain get off like this in
a minute
yeah classic [ __ ] like i feel like um
with this project you you're in a really
great position to kind of um
you know i feel like people kind of
associate you as like nips homie
right yeah that's my day one right but
but i think that this album is like
an album that is kind of like it feels
like you're
like you're a rival where you're it's
like yeah that's that's
that's j stone who happens to be
nipsey's homie like you know
you understand what i'm trying to say i
mean i kind of get it
yeah like i feel like this album is like
a big statement for you as an artist
actually
exactly like that like i say like the
definition of loyalty was like
it was like a demonstration but this one
is like
like [ __ ] it's my snap right here like
this [ __ ] was for real and it is for
real and i'm here so get used to me you
feel me
what do you like what's your thoughts on
um
you know a lot of these lists have been
coming out and i feel like obviously
la is always getting overlooked you know
head always talks about that shout out
to head
um a lot of hip hop media is east coast
biased
um what is your kind of thought process
on where l.a hip-hop is right now
i mean [ __ ] i think we in a good space
right now everybody doing that [ __ ] man
shout out to everybody on the west
that's doing that [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying lyrically
and you know i'm saying [ __ ]
i just feel like you know you can say
like
the west need this and the west need
that and
we don't need this and we don't need
that but if [ __ ] if you actually
everybody else bro on the outside
looking in
we looking good i mean listen you're
sounding good
i also feel like there's a lot more
unity right now
yeah in l.a than in the past for sure
especially with the younger kids that
are doing their thing you know for sure
and it could be a lot more
it could be a lot more that's probably
like the only thing that we lack you
feel what i'm saying because the south
they go do songs with each other
you know what i'm saying they gonna sit
in the studio and do
10 records one day right look here's a
21 savage offset album
yeah exactly like i don't know i work
like that that's how i work
right now i'm saying i don't think
[ __ ] can get in the studio with me
like that
you know what i'm saying do you think
it's it's a lot of it is
uh is the politics side of l.a sometimes
just kind of you know not necessarily
not they don't know that not that
somebody doesn't [ __ ] with
an artist but it's like sometimes it's
like look well like
you know sometimes the politics kind of
get in the middle of of certain people
collaborating you know what i'm saying
definitely like like i remember that's
kind of like everywhere you go now
though
if you think about it i mean that's just
pretty much anywhere in hip-hop like
in the industry i mean it's really out
here though for sure as far as you know
i'm talking about the street politics
yeah the street politics yeah like
because there was bro as a fan i was i
was always
there was like one of the one record i
always like one of the one
collabs i wanted i wanted to hear nipsey
and schoolboy q want some [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying
and you know obviously there's no secret
if you're from l.a as to why that
probably didn't happen
it wasn't like there was beef or
anything but i feel like that there's
definitely like
you know with the young kids right now
at least like the one take jays the hazy
chikes
you know the um the shoreline kids uh
ruchi like it feels like there's just a
lot more camaraderie with the younger
generation in la right now and it's just
good to see man
for sure yeah who were you um
you we were talking earlier like man i'm
a hip-hop head
you know definitely bro cause you know
what i'm saying i was
out boy bro growing up in this [ __ ] bro
we have to box
you know what i'm saying of course the
video channel the box yeah like come on
you know what i'm saying
[ __ ] like that the box was crazy and
then uh
you know my cousins and [ __ ] you know
they used to always listen to all that
80s rap
before me so i was i was already i was
already listening to that [ __ ] what's
your fav what's your favorite like
like give me like your top three albums
of all time if you could
and then excluding victory lap because
that's got to be in there i'm assuming
i mean victory lap is just all you know
what i'm saying that's just up there you
already know
of course of course you know i'm saying
my top three
damn man [ __ ] number one
me against the world poc okay um
[ __ ] you can throw you can throw uh
bone thugs or harmony creeping on the
come up or each 99 internal on there hey
one of them talking about um
and number three [ __ ]
definition the loyalty okay i see you
you put yourself in there yeah yo it was
crazy because like like bone thugs was
uh
i remember having uh creeping on a come
up and the ouija board [ __ ] as look
that's a little my [ __ ] bro as a little
kid that [ __ ] creeped me out though
yo because i was like but i love bone
bone creeping on a come up and doggy
style that was hard
but like hard they like the main reason
why i'm rapping right
man and they don't get in i don't feel
like they don't get talked about enough
anymore like as far as when we're
talking about the all-time greatest
groups and [ __ ] like bones up there man
like yeah
they up there everybody know what they
have wrong
millions of records bro east 1999
millions of [ __ ] heard it
grammys and they got the grammys come on
man it ain't it ain't it ain't
too many [ __ ] it ain't really
too many [ __ ] yeah
you know bone bones uh you know
i wish they would have had a longer run
for sure yeah a hundred percent
shout out my name is [ __ ] up the
business side yeah i mean listen when
you guys
when you got that many people involved
in a group it's hard to you know
you got to manage a lot more variables
yeah you know people
and then and then crazy bones start
doing solo [ __ ] lazy bone dropped the
solo out and then busy dropped the solo
it was like you know then [ __ ] just kind
of got out of control i feel like but
shout out to bone man legendary group
shout out respect to them yo look man
quick break from the podcast to tell you
about odd socks all right they're our
official sponsor they support what we do
here at the bootleg kit podcast
all right they got the nickelodeon
joints they got these uh
yo shout out to ghostbusters i might
keep those um anyway
what you gotta do is hit that
oddsoxofficial.com
if you want to support what i do the
bootleghead podcast then support our
partners odd socks go buy some socks man
holidays are coming up odd
socksofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev you're getting 20
off of the most comfortable socks in the
world
shout out to odd socks um is there
obviously you're probably sitting on a
whole lot more music
what's the plans for 2021 for you bro
[ __ ] man
i don't know what it's gonna look like
man hopefully they open these doors man
and we get on the road
right get back on this road and [ __ ] if
not bro i'm back in the studio
recreating it doing another album you
feel me
just keep keeping them pushing yeah
keeping it pushing them and then
whatever happens along the process is
going to happen bro cuz
i don't know right right right can you
kind of i was gonna ask you can you kind
of give us um like an update obviously
for people who don't know the marathon
store physical location was
was closed right yeah um but you can
still go online and support
definitely go online and support and get
the merchandise you know what i'm saying
marathon.com
yeah marathonclothing.com yeah because i
it was you know after nips passing i
just remember like
that became you know i think it's always
gonna be a um
a landmark you know where people whoever
comes to town they're gonna go
and be like yo this is where nipsey's
business was this is where you know what
i'm saying like yeah where it started
you know i'm saying from ground zero
like that was ground zero right there
yeah it's crazy because if you like you
know through the whole process of him
being there getting kicked out of that
area
then to opening the store up and then to
just being everybody's landlord and that
[ __ ] like
it's it's it was like such a dope uh
story and i think like
that i don't know what the current you
know situation of that uh center is but
i think that like it's got to be
preserved man
like you know it was uh i think in like
20 or 30 years from now we're going to
be watching
the nipsy hustle movie it might even be
10 years from now 20 30 years from now
that's
a long time it might be 10 it might be
10 years from now oh yeah it's time
[ __ ] it might be 10 years you know
definitely definitely
who's playing who's playing j stone in
that movie though
[ __ ] me forget me
like the younger me i don't know what if
you got you gotta pick an actor though
a younger me somebody yeah but me i'll
definitely go with me you feel me but if
not
i don't know i don't know i can't think
of nobody right now
all right well listen the album is out
um the definition of pain man dope body
of work
is there gonna be yo has lebron james
heard the lebron james
record yet yeah i sent it to him did he
[ __ ] with it yeah he [ __ ] with it
yeah i'm saying he gonna go crazy
he was the first person i sent it to
right when it was mix and master
i hit him like yeah press play it must
be nice to just be able to hit lebron
james
yeah bro that's 100. for sure for sure
motivation i keep a [ __ ] going to you
for me
any other videos um do you have videos
in the can for the further from there
what videos are dropping [ __ ] i got one
with e40
i got one with davies another one yeah
yeah yeah yeah so yeah we crashed boom
j stone man appreciate you pulling up go
support the album the definition of pain
is
out let's go yeah freestyle out right
now too
actually let's go let's get it boom
perfect